(upbeat rock music)
(audience clapping)
♪ You run, run, you run away ♪
♪ It's your heart that you betray ♪
♪ Feeding on your hungry eyes ♪
♪ I bet you're not so civilized ♪
♪ Well, isn't love primitive ♪
♪ A wild gift that you wanna give ♪
♪ Break out of captivity ♪
♪ And follow me stereo jungle child ♪
♪ Love is the kill ♪
♪ You're heart's still wild ♪
♪ Shootin' at the walls of heartache ♪
♪ I am the warrior ♪
♪ Well, I am the warrior ♪
♪ And heart to heart you'll win ♪
♪ If you survive ♪
♪ The warrior ♪
♪ I am the warrior ♪
- Yeah!
(upbeat rock music)
♪ Whoo ♪
♪ Shootin' at the walls of heartache ♪
♪ The warrior ♪
♪ I am the warrior ♪
♪ And heart to heart you'll win ♪
♪ If you survive ♪
♪ The warrior ♪
(audience cheering and clapping)